Look at all this stuff!
Soaps, lotions, conditioners, polishes -- all
from that huge section of your local store
that’s dedicated solely to the grooming
of your skin, hair, and nails.
Some might see these things as the trappings
of vanity.
But me? I see them as the tools for the care,
maintenance, and -- sure, sometimes decoration
-- of the integumentary system.
Now, true, in spite of what the cosmetics
industry may lead you to believe, your integumentary
system is more than just a place to put eye shadow
and hair product in the hopes of attracting a mate.
This collection of resilient tissues, ranging
from the sharp and hard to the soft and fluffy,
serve a whole panoply of functions, the majority
of which you never even notice.
But, when you do notice what your integumentary
system is doing, the results are often uncomfortable
or ugly or both, and that is what this stuff
is mostly for.
Your sweat glands can make you smell.
Your oil glands can give you zits.
Your skin can become either scaly or greasy,
and -- in rare cases -- it can even change color.
And hair, well, let’s just say it takes
a lot of science to tame this mane.
But each of these tissues -- frustrating as
they may be at times -- has a purpose, and
without them you’d be cold and vulnerable
and dead.
I’m not gonna lecture you on personal hygiene
today. But hopefully by the end of this you’ll
understand the important functions of your
integumentary system, and maybe why it’s
worth a little bit of time and effort to keep
it healthy.
And hey, it might even score you a date.
If you recall our recent run-ins with rogue
nails and tattoo needles, you’ll probably
remember that the first and most vital purpose
of your integumentary system is to act as
a protective barrier.
Your skin, hair, nails and sweat and oil glands
all work together to shield you from all the
things out there that are out to get you:
excessive sunlight, infections, abrasions,
and just, you know, getting poked by sharp
sticks and stuff.
But beyond that, this system is also vital
to how you sense the world around you.
Your skin is loaded with structures that are
actually part of your nervous system -- called
cutaneous sensory receptors -- they’re what
receive stimuli from the outside environment
and send them to your brain.
These receptors, or corpuscles, as they’re
sometimes called, register all of the different
sensations that you associate with touch.
Your tactile corpuscles, for instance, are
what make you constantly aware of the tag
that’s scratching at the back of your neck,
while your lamellar corpuscles register the
sense of pressure, like when someone puts
their hand on your shoulder.
Your hair follicles have receptors, too, which
is why you can feel a slight breeze on your
skin or through your hair.
Now, on the less-sexy front, your integumentary
system also plays a role in the excretion
of waste, though not as big as a role as we’re
often led to believe.
Most nitrogen-containing wastes like urea,
uric acid, and ammonia are disposed of through
your urine, but small amounts are eliminated
through your skin in sweat.
But despite what you may be told at the beginning
of your hot-yoga class, there isn’t much
evidence that suggests that heavy sweating
actually rids your body of any extra toxins
-- if anything, you’re just losing more
water.
When you do exercise, though, you call on
another of your skin’s lesser-known functions
-- as a handy blood storage unit.
About 5 percent of your entire blood volume
is retained in your skin at any given time.
And when you suddenly need more blood supplied
to your organs, like when you’re working out,
your nervous system constricts your dermal blood
vessels to squeeze that extra blood into circulation.
Now, during these times of exertion, both
your blood and your sweat glands work together
to perform a key function: regulating your
body temperature.
Even without exercise, your body oozes out
about half a liter of sweat per day, in an
effort to keep you at a comfortable temperature.
That’s just your normal, barely noticeable
sweat called insensible perspiration.
But on a hot day, or if you’re on the dance
floor exerting yourself, that sweat becomes
much more noticeable. Such sensible perspiration could
produce as much as 12 LITERS of sweat per day!
Now, if the temperature gets chilly, the surface
of your skin can lose a lot of heat, because
it has so much warm blood behind it. To regulate
that heat loss, your dermal blood vessels
constrict, causing your blood to head deeper
into your tissues and help keep your vital organs warm.
Once things warm up, those blood vessels in
the skin gradually relax, and allow that blood
to return to the surface.
You’ve probably noticed that if you’re
cold for too long, your skin may lose some
of its color -- or even turn pale blue if
you’re light-skinned -- as that blood retreats
from the surface.
And in fact, like a litmus test for your body,
changes in the color of your skin can indicate
a number of homeostatic imbalances.
Blue skin, or cyanosis, in Caucasian people
may indicate heart failure, poor circulation,
or severe respiratory issues. That’s because
blood that’s been depleted of oxygen turns
darker in color, and when seen through the
tissue of lips or skin, it can look bluish.
A yellowing of the skin, called jaundice,
usually signifies liver disorder, as yellow
bile starts accumulating in the blood stream.
Reddened skin, or erythema, could indicate
a fever, inflammation, or allergy -- all of
these conditions cause blood vessels to expand
and more blood to flow to the skin’s surface.
Of course, human skin color spans a pretty
wide spectrum, so some of these conditions
are easier to diagnose by looking for discolorations
of other tissues, like mucous membranes and
the beds of finger and toenails.
However light or dark your skin color is,
though, you can thank your melanin for it.
You’ll remember that melanin is a pigment
produced by the melanocyte cells in your epidermis.
Melanin has two forms, producing pigments
that range in color from reddish yellow to
brownish black.
Because its main job is to protect us from
the sun’s ultraviolet rays, it makes sense
that, in the distant past, the distribution of these
different skin tones was not at all random.
Historically, where solar radiation is more
intense, higher concentrations of deep-colored
melanin became an advantage for the protection
it provided.
But closer to the poles, where those solar
rays are weaker and more diffuse, lower concentrations
of melanin allowed people to collect what
sunlight was available, to manufacture vitamin D.
‘Cause the fact is, we all need some level
of sunlight to hit our skin to survive.
Your bones require vitamin D to keep producing
new bone cells, and it’s the only vitamin
that your body can actually produce on its
own. Your skin cells contain a molecule that
converts to vitamin D when it comes in contact
with UV light.
From there the vitamin heads through your
bloodstream to your liver and kidneys where
it truly becomes activated D, also called calcitriol,
which is circulated to all the bones of your body.
But let’s not just be skin-deep here -- your
integumentary system also involves your so-called
skin appendages -- your hair, nails, sweat
and sebaceous, or oil glands, which can each
be fascinating as well as frustrating in its
own way.
If you’re like some people I know and you
spend a fortune on hair conditioner? That’s
because your cuticles are out of control.
All of your hairs, or pili, are basically
just flexible strands of dead keratin protein
cells, like your fingernails.
And the outermost layer of these dead cells,
called the cuticle, looks like it’s made
of overlapping roof shingles. So what you’re
paying the conditioner to do is even out the
rough surface between those cells of the cuticle
to make it look smooth.
Now if you pluck out a strand of your hair
you will be in pain, but you will also have
the opportunity to notice that it has two
main regions -- the shaft -- where the keratinization
is complete -- and the root -- the part inside the
follicle where keratinization is still happening.
Each follicle is just a tube of epidermal
cells, and just like in your epidermis, the
cells at the bottom of each follicle are young
and fresh, continually dividing and pushing
older cells up through the skin and into the
open air.
And your finger- and toenails pretty much
grow the same way -- starting at the back
of the nail bed where new cells divide at
the root and get pushed forward, creating
the scaly-hard keratin that you paint with
polish and keep trimmed during flip-flop season.
But there’s probably no other part of the
integumentary system that you spend more money
on trying to control than your sweat and oil
glands.
You’ve got up to three million tiny sudoriferous,
or sweat glands distributed throughout your
body. These guys secrete your salty, watery
sweat, and they come in two types: eccrine
and apocrine.
Your eccrine sweat glands are more abundant
-- they’re in your palms, forehead, and
in the soles of your feet.
They’re just simple coiled tubes that start
in the dermis, extend through a duct, and
open into a pore on the surface of your skin.
Your apocrine sweat glands are a slightly
different story. You only have about 2000
of these, and they start cookin’ around
puberty, emptying into the hair follicles
around your armpits and groin.
These glands secrete a kind of deluxe sweat,
with fats and proteins in it. It’s more
viscous and sometimes yellowish in color.
When bacteria on the skin get a hold of this
sweat, it gets odorific, creating what we
generically call body odor.
Deodorants don’t affect how much you sweat,
but they do reduce those smells by attacking
the stink-making bacteria, while antiperspirants
do the opposite, using ingredients like aluminum
to block your sweat glands and actually keep
you from perspiring.
Some researchers believe these glands may
be the human equivalent of other animals’
musky sex scent glands. So while you might
not want to stink up a whole room, a little
bit of body odor might actually get you a
mate.
Mammary glands, which secrete milk in lactating
people, and ceruminous glands, the ones that
make your cerumen, or earwax, are two other
types of modified apocrine sweat glands.
Finally, your sebaceous, or oil glands are
found everywhere but the thick skin in your
palms and foot soles. Their ducts are smaller
on your limbs, but they’re pretty big on
your face, and neck, and upper chest.
Most of your sebaceous glands secrete their
sebum, an oily substance, into hair follicles
where it can travel to the surface of your
skin.
And while yes, they cause wicked pimples,
their primary goal is to soften and lubricate
your skin and hair, and help slow water loss
from the skin in dry environments.
Try to remember that the next time you have
a break-out before a big date or job interview.
Maybe it’ll make you feel better. It probably
won’t.
The irony here is that about half of the things
I showed at the beginning of this episode
are used to wash away our natural protective
moisturizing oils, while the other half are
there to add them back through lotions and
conditioners!
Deodorant, though. I think we’re all glad
that exists.
Today you learned how your integumentary system
protects your body, senses the outside world,
helps excrete waste, stores blood, regulates
temperature, makes vitamin D, indicates signs
of poor health, and gives you zits. We also
talked about how your hair and nails grow,
the difference between your eccrine and apocrine
sweat glands, and your sebaceous oil glands.
Thank you for watching, especially to all
of our Subbable subscribers, who make Crash
Course possible for themselves and also to
everyone else. To find out how you can become
a supporter, just go to subbable.com.
This episode was written by Kathleen Yale,
edited by Blake de Pastino, and our consultant,
is Dr. Brandon Jackson. Our director and editor
is Nicholas Jenkins, the script supervisor
and sound designer is Michael Aranda, and
the graphics team is Thought Café.